mi scusi capi presi
comunque
molto tant'è vero che con ma senza
ucciso anche su iniziato presto un
giocatore grandi dove troviamo il di
studi abitare
[Musica]
è uscito un nuovissimo gioco guardato e
questa è la nuova nonna alla nuova
tirreni sa qualcosa di libertà del naso
mi fa abbastanza schifo
infatti questa nuova granny non lascia
scopriremo assieme come come sempre
mettetevi comodi pre di bruca online mi
piace e iniziamo questo nuovissimo zona
siena
eccoci qua musicale anita e vitale ok
vabbè allontanare allora che cosa
dobbiamo fare questo gioco sicuramente
scappare dalla mamma nonna parte dice
trova i biscotti della nonna ok come
obiettivo la prendiamo ora non si vede
ma secondo me farà più paura questa
nuova nonna o granny originale trendy
originale credo io vado subito a trovare
biscotti però libero mangiarli e
[Musica]
guarda guarda dice
io sto scappando dalla nonna ripeto chi
l'ha detto che vuole che ci siamo rinati
b totti
piuttosto mi rivolge i biscotti roma
comunque è fortissimo allora ho preso la
chiave dove devo andare adesso vai su
nell'attico fa paura
ci sei riuscita nou dove dove dove
notare piccolo prova riesco sciopero
ho appreso vediamo se sa neanche qua no
non credo che lavorava nella cantina ma
sopra eccole lo vedete doveva si è
addormentata ma rimane lì a dormire ok
io sto arrivando che la chiave della
poppata dell'astico alunni ma anche il
mio prato trovato
aperto a nuotare eccomi prevendita
frollano attento perché qua accadono
pure le mattonelle a me ne sono accorto
allora diamo un nome a questa nuova
granny se non la confondiamo champion su
terreni
bruttissima grandi pasticciona perché
farà fare i biscotti niente perché c'era
però non tramuta paura grady pasticciona
biscotti più altri due biscotti vapori
siamo questo da lei diciamo che a
michele fanno paura le cose che non
fanno paura
figo guarda ci sono degli altri
giocatori qui
per i giocatori ma attenzione sembra sia
molto facile essere presi da queste
trappole per i medici voi nei commenti
come volete chiamare questa nuova nona
nuova cattiva scrivetecelo nei commenti
e poi sceglieremo il 9 con più mi piace
sarà il mondo con cui chiameremo sempre
questa nonna g ufficiale il nome di
grande ufficiale
viene spiegato gli analisti sono
tantissimi
sono avanti comunque stato impattato per
ora non riuscirono a vincere io privo di
vita che cosa devo fare adesso però
scappare dalla casa beh penso proprio di
sì di vita ci sei subito
devi scendere nella tomba ma non ci
pensano i medici si è appreso ti ha
detto c'e di nella tomba
timide cookies back che vuol dire
ridammi dei topi che
hanno innescato da vin vescovo le voci
trasformerà in 3d
anche
[Musica]
ok ora prova andare
trova tutto grava si
vede non c'è non c'è loro io lo vedo non
lo so perché potrei besta ha fatto una
brutta fine ma non c'è in giro è legata
buona del po poco c'è mancato poco che
mi sfracellasi attenta quando scendi qui
è facile vedere si sente guerra assenti
avete sentito qualcuno che restava che
siamo andati a fermentata no ero io non
sto mangiare biscotti vino incluso quasi
strada e ti biscotti
spacciato come ho fatto solo dell'arno
quindi ora dove stiamo in una sorta di
castello torre della nonna cielo resta
della nostra zona da una frana spero
comunque alla fine che scopriamo che
cosa nasconderlo si accorda un censore
come sempre ci stai volando e basta
mario sei dimenticato di mettere mutande
a chi sta peggio
è stato il re altissima ma soprattutto
perché non ci sono altri giocatori
che avevano avuto perso parte dei
pantaloni
guarda tutti i giocatori che hanno
provato a superare questo stupro una
nota una brutta fine attenta che si
scivola o mucchietto
l'aiutante bisogno a testa
cisoni stato preso da un giocatore ho
capito parte il nipote della nonna sono
altri dietro sono tifoso un pil
io
sono tutti i suoi nipoti oppure i
giocatori che apre secondo me i
giocatori che ha preso forma di zombie
[Musica]
no vicolo cieco che qui
troviamo quattro che io seguo terni ta
non lo so se
piccolo dei motori ma succede vicolo
cieco strega
aiuto
per fortuna che doveva seguita guarda
invece una corda siamo in un posto wow
siamo tornati sopra quindi ce l'ha
detto che formano vedo dov'è forse tutti
spero di dare il mio team abbiamo
appreso
spesso principito che cosa sta
succedendo
sono entrata di voi in uno scantinato o
nome preso di nuovo la nonna mi prese
sempre vendere nello scantinato e quelli
si addormentino ok aspettami allora
avete
ecco
che mi sta dormendo unico perché tutti
addormenta ma dove sono gli altri
giocatori perché siamo datori che
succede qua che cosa succede
è difficile
spetta mita guarda guarda avanti come tu
sei qui fiero di te che proviamo ad
andare da qui vedi che ci sono altri
finizio approvato quattro canti
allora come cavolo si fa saltare la
soprano cappuccio è fatto si va pero non
potendo più alto come fatto lo devi solo
prendere un po di
[Musica]
rincorsa dai se ce l'ho fatta io puoi
farcela anche tu ok io sono intanto fa
ma ora dobbiamo fare il tifo per vietata
dismessi ma adesso non mi piace
lasciatevi piace per portare fortuna
vitale e se non avete ancora il mio
libro storie paurose a scuola dei
misteri lake affermi che descrisse per
prenderlo trovate stuart ha messo
libreria e per entrare a far parte della
stessa
scappare lisa ci sono quasi tutti
facciano non credere che cammina questa
di quanto
bravo questa porta
che succede siamo tornati indietro vuole
fare una corsa
nov il padre mattina
no secondo me finisce a vita o vitale
vitale dice perché è troppo bravo sfugge
parti è venuta non mi sono più care
d'italia e di parlando mina dove non
certo sì volevo dire che mi sono appena
presentato che
posso vincere è mai visto che c'è il tie
dye non l'ho visto non perdiamo mi sono
stragelato di nuovo non ci penso lei
stava quasi l'ultima come fatto dura dal
nostro dell'arte neanche una volta sto
andando piano che va piano
vero se ci ha frenato è vero è qui ma ho
vinto nella gara con il tempo di 52 con
il miur hanno trovato peggio no no il
badge non andava il rum che perfetto
quindi sono fare il tempo a prendere
badge vediamo se vediamo vediamo se vi
diamo vita e arrivare ma quanto sei
stato eletto tantissimo con quella
macchinetta dei superman sono caduto di
botto mila volte vediamo apriamo la
porta no perché non mi fa passare è
perché bisogna fare stop previsto
solamente
che ho battuto in gara
passato con la palla che mi ascoltate
attenzione allora fai passare la palla
per primo forse bisogna nascondersi
quello sì sì sì sì sono sempre dicevamo
diversi giuda non una parte ci ho
provato io mi sono sfracellato alla
scala che queste scordiamoci aspetta
aspettano valutare di oggi è fighissimo
che schifo mi piace un sacco ce la porta
qui guarda grazie a quell'ora
salvataggio sono troppe che c'è la casa
sull'albero
ciechi bazooka
zuccari biscotti e proprio sul giovane
guardia mostrare i buchi grandi dove
primaria mai vissuti abitare e questa
grande
forza perché le vedute
numero di eventi batte troppo figo
nuovo destro trova offerto non troppo
aiuto è davvero difficile si no non
soltanto inferiore a prenderle tutte ma
noi ci proviamo a fare schemi potevo
farlo
ma come si può 31 me tutto aiuto davis
paramento direzione non farli avvicinare
o no mi hanno preso a maggio ma
sono troppe ma se mi metto tipo contro
il muro e forse forse riesco a prenderla
è meglio non so dove sono sentito come
facevi un'opa atene hanno già retro o
sono tantissime che cosa ha deciso
che ultimi tema che hai avuto non ci
sono le scale quindi non è possibile
comunque fa paura quando capita così
madonna
che stiamo indicando il nome preso il
sonno
no ma buffa è troppo difficile non va
bene questo ok proviamo a scappare qua
no allora si può innamorare di sé nei
biscotti rimaniamo con le spalle su
questa cosa nostra che si porta di
angeles ei tutti proprio perché
riconosce essere finito soprattutto
[Musica]
quante sono e lo sta facendo vita più o
meno nell'ultimo modello d'occhio
ok forse ho capito forse bisogna sempre
spostarsi corre incontro a loro perché
tanto loro sono lente ok io proprio
questa tecnica per ora
forse così possiamo fare
che provo a muovermi presenazione
vediamo se non ci mangiamo dopo
mannaggia
spesso per difficile comunque troppo
pensa di questa etichetta il pescara di
questa
via via via via andate via per sempre no
anche tu beccati questo
lo vedete via
via via via via altri vedendo forte si è
fatta
davvero si situa trotta è apparsa la
scala davvero non ci credo vediamo e che
aspetta che il prof usata primorac io
se l'uscita
che cosa succede il badge
davvero ce l'ha fatta ci crederò mai
vista la bellissima e qui c'è una
macchinetta posso scegliere
recandoci
correndo mondo dove si andrà da noi non
ha detto nel mondo livelli la spettacolo
non sono uscite le revoche uniamo
abbiamo vinto a fare il signori abbiamo
bach bravissimi sono uscito piccioli
appuntamenti meno nette no no no vedo
che corri dondo e problemi minare
bravi semplicemente di guidarle non ci
posso fare è stato difficilissimo e
fatti sì ho fatto cedere ceres
tantissimo ci si impara 26 parati sì sì
sì sì sì sì se si fosse più c'è un certo
senso voto prenderlo subito e poi prende
la macchina e facciamo una gara finale
ok ok che hai preso no no sempre sto
salendo perché sono caduto dalle scale
ok ho preso il belgio
prendo adesso la macchina e
allora mettiamoci poi in posizione
aspetta che faccia manovra e vediamo che
arriva per primo la porta ok mi aspetto
che non ti vedo dove sei behrami regina
qua aspetto devo fare manovra demo
partita prima gara pronti a senza io
faccio
tre bravi a
chi arriverà prima chi arriverà le
[Musica]
bestie pro photolab
attivissimo
e giocosa e divertente per tutti fu di
creme ora veniamo
faticare per vedere i nostri altri video
il caso su quella preferita